hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
how the heck is it the holidays already
also check out my holiday nails well
these are thanksgiving nails so today in
this video i wanted to do like a holiday
gift guide sort of thing for you all
been adult for a while now so i've been
through a lot of christmases where i do
the gifting and there's a lot of items
that i've noticed that i really enjoy
using that i think would be really great
gifts to give for this holiday time so
whether you're giving that gift to a
friend or a family member significant
other a mentor maybe you gotta bring a
gift for white elephant or secret santa
or heck maybe you're gifting something
for yourself because we all deserve
something every once in a while
especially during the holiday time
because yes as a japanese american
millennial woman who has a tech
background is now doing this creative
work i like stuff like i like good stuff
so i wanted to talk about the stuff
hopefully it'll help you all to give
something really great to a very special
person this holiday season thank you so
much to felix gray for sponsoring this
video we'll talk a little bit about
their glasses which is one of the items
on my gift guide in a bit but a lot of
the other items are things that i've
also been gifted or i have affiliate
links to so i'll leave everything in the
description box down below so that you
can check it out regardless all the
things on this gift guide are things
that i genuinely do recommend i wouldn't
recommend things that i don't think you
should buy i mean all of my sponsors are
ones that i genuinely like using or like
working with
all right so let's talk water bottles
because
we're all using reusable water bottles
by now right i hope you are because
that's one of the easiest ways to like
reduce your footprint on the earth and
make sure that you're not creating more
waste than you need to be and so i hope
you have a bottle but in going through
lots of different kinds of bottles i
found that these ones 24 bottles are
actually like the best water bottle so
i've used water bottles from hydro flask
and yeti and other water bottles that
are insulated really heavy duty can hold
a lot of water which i like them for
that purpose but the cons are they're
all really really heavy like they could
be used as like a weapon i feel like in
some cases and a lot of them don't fit
into like cup holders and cars they
don't fit into my side pocket and my
backpack they're also just not like
easily carryable which i bring water
bottle to shopping to errands to friends
houses and so i'm realizing how
important it is for me to have a water
bottle that's just like easy to carry
which is why i really really like these
ones what i like about them is that
they're not too big they're also really
light so the weight of what you're
carrying is mostly water like i don't
know how much this weighs but i'll weigh
it in a little bit i also don't know how
much this holds i want to say probably a
little over
a pint probably like a little over a
liter kind of thing but i use these for
travel i use these for work also
the top part too really easy to drink
from also really easy to clean fuss-free
i've had these for
three years i think so you can tell that
they're kind of like banged up and stuff
but they look really nice
so scott and i really really like coffee
like whenever we go on trips coffee is
one of our main goals so we map out all
these different third wave coffee places
and we go there and it's always a fun
time we did that for a reason trip to
new york so yeah we have a lot of coffee
gadgets at home one of which is the
chemex which this is definitely
something that i'd like to recommend
probably a lot of you have them already
we've had this one for probably five
years i want to say it just makes really
good pour overs it looks really pretty
on our counter as well so if you have a
coffee enthusiast in your life or you
really wanted to try what else there is
out there in the coffee world other than
like starbucks coffee then get this and
a good bag of beans and a good grinder
and start with that but the real thing
that i want to recommend is for anybody
who already has a chemix or v60 and
really kind of wants to take it a step
further this is the aeropress and yeah
it's a weird contraption but it makes
coffee this was invented by the same
inventor who made a frisbee and it's
meant to make like the perfect cup of
coffee so we've also had this for a
really long time but it wasn't until
this year that we really kind of started
using it a lot more because we watched
james hoffman's video about how to brew
a really good cup of aeropress and all
the different factors that go into it
and whether it makes a difference
because there's so many different brew
methods like there's literally an
aeropress like world championship or
something like that started off in noro
with like a group of four people and now
it's actually like a really big thing
but
i use this to brew really really good
pour overs um primarily it's really
great because the bean to water to
filter ratio is really good like you're
getting maximum extraction out of the
beans so you're able to get more of the
different notes and acidity and notes
and tones and stuff like that of coffee
that would be typically hard to get
through something like a chemex or
something else and so this
this is just this is a cool thing i'll
link the james hoffman video down in the
description box down below but yeah the
way that it works is that there's
actually a little filter part here i
actually use this to bring my morning
coffee so it's in the dishwasher there's
a little thing here cap here the filter
goes here you put your beans in you put
your water in you put this plunger thing
in what i do is i leave it in there for
like two minutes and let the coke the
coffee and the water mingle together and
then you just press down and then it
like extracts the water out you're not
supposed to press that hard but it's
just kind of hard because there's
nothing else in here right now really
interesting coffee contraption it's
really not even that expensive i think
it's like 30
and it makes for a great coffee travel
kit speaking of coffee
all right next on my list is shoes shoes
really important as you get older you
realize how important good shoes are to
like your health and your back and your
knees and be able to walk for miles and
miles and miles and like making sure
it's versatile and you can wear it with
different clothing options at least
these are all really important things to
me for shoes a year about a year ago i
did a video with vessi who makes these
shoes that i wanted to recommend to
everybody so no longer sponsored by them
but i have had them for over a year
shoes are a lot dirtier but they're the
same ones from that video which we'll
play a little clip of but these are
waterproof they're so comfy they fit
like a sock
i have worn them like every day and what
i really like about them is that they
really are just like the perfect shoe
for everything and anything whether that
be going for a little walk um going for
travel i also work out in these shoes i
lift in them and we took them out
recently to again our new york trip
where it rained so much that day and
scott and i both wore our vessies and
our socks weren't wet and so just been
really really happy with these i'm
thinking about getting a second pair
because i like them so much and i really
recommend these specifically i also like
these more than like similar competitor
shoes i guess because i think the shape
of them just makes my legs look
elongated because your girl has short
ass asian legs and so i can't be wearing
shoes that makes my legs look even
shorter which is why i really like these
because they make my legs look long
alright so the next item that i wanted
to talk about which i talked about in a
recent video actually is this bellroy
sling i was sponsored by bellroy this
year and ever since they sent me this i
have the mini sling in this kind of cute
tan yellow color
i have used nothing but this for
everyday carry for everyday errands also
for travel
is what i tested out recently this is
perfect they do have a larger version
which i haven't tried but i'm like not a
large huge person so i wanted to get
this small one because i thought it
would kind of fit my proportions better
but yeah definitely really really like
this one
next thing that i wanted to recommend is
for any of you all or maybe you have
friends or family who you think could
have a little bit of greenery in their
life i recommend plants as a gift so i
know that a lot of people in quarantine
have really taken affinity to house
plans so if you haven't reached that yet
let me introduce you house plans are
great and i'm going to introduce two of
my favorite houseplants that i think
make great gifts and also great
companions and also great things to just
like have in your house the first is
this one this is a pothos plant i've had
this one in my room for only a few
months but it's really really easy to
take care of it's one of like the like
beginner plants that are like not hard
to take care of their they also sell
them everywhere this one actually i
propagated off of a really old pathos
plant that my family had i think we've
had it for like 20 years and we've just
propagated that thing into like at least
15 other pathos plants like this one so
it's one of those things that if you buy
it once you really don't have to buy it
again and you can just keep propagating
and propagating talked about how i
propagate pot those plants in a vlog of
mine which i'll link
here but yeah it just adds some really
nice greenery this one specifically i
have a variegated version and so some of
the leaves have this nice like light
green as well which they get variegated
if you leave them in direct sunlight so
super easy to take care of if you leave
it on top of a bookshelf or something
like that after it gets really leggy
just add some really nice warmth and
green into your room this one
is the second plant that i recommend
this is a monstera deliciosa monsteria
plants you probably see them also all
over the internet these are also
incredibly easy to take care of we
actually got a monster like a baby one
at the beginning of 2019 and that one's
grown really large and this one was
propagated off of that one so similar to
the pathos plant once you have one and
you take care of it and it gets bigger
then you can make cuttings and make
any number like exponential number of
more monstera plans so these make for
really really good gifts because if you
already have a monstera then it's free
to basically make a gift for somebody
and they're really nice because they
take up like it's like a medium sized
plant it can get really really big it's
got this really nice green the newer
leaves tend to be kind of like this
light green as well and it's got the
holes it's just a really pretty plant
also incredibly easy to take care of i
water mine about once a week i water it
really deeply and i've put them in like
dark rooms really bright rooms just as
long as it's not in direct sunlight it's
also really easy to tell when this guy's
not happy or when it's like needs water
or something like that the leaves just
kind of go huh monstera and pothos
highly recommend
so the next item that i wanted to talk
about is also the sponsor of today's
video felix gray
y'all have seen me wear these glasses a
bunch in my videos these are like my
computer glasses i wear these all the
freaking time and so really happy to be
working with felix gray for this video
so these are the blue light glasses that
started it all they set out to create
eyewear to improve daily screen time and
now they're on a mission to help people
have a better relationship with
technology which that's what i'm all
about that's like that's me i want to
have a better relationship with
technology i want you all to have a
better relationship with technology and
ourselves and how can we as software
engineers also make better technology
for ourselves in the future so yeah
this is my jam phyllis grays filter out
15 times more blue light that can make
screen time tough on the eyes and can be
really disruptive to sleep i personally
have a robling and amber toffee in the
low nose bridge fit because your girl
has an asian face and she needs that
extra little bit of support because she
doesn't have a big nose so these are
really great they don't rest on my face
they rest on my nose just like how
glasses should and i love them literally
have been using them every single day
for about a year and these would
honestly make great gifts for anybody
who spends a lot of time in front of the
screen they make these blue light
glasses they make sleep glasses they
also make sunglasses and they have a lot
of different cool styles to choose from
right now felix gray is offering 15 off
of everything so use code everything15
at checkout the offer is valid from
november 23rd to december 2nd 2021. i
just can't live without these anymore
genuinely when i look at my screen
without these i can feel it i also have
a little bit of like reading glass
magnitude in these as well so it
magnifies everything yeah i just can't
look at screens without them now so
really really important necessity in my
life and i think can make a great gift
next on the list is those who just love
stationery i know we live in a digital
world but i still really like stationery
and so i want to recommend my favorite
notebook and pens favorite notebook
being the midori notebook is this a
surprise no many people i've talked to
have said this is the best notebook out
there this one i specifically have the
a5 size in the grid paper midori
notebooks are the smoothest like the
paper is the smoothest i've ever felt
and also
it lays flat and it comes with like a
little bookmark too i've used these for
like kanji practice i've used them for
bullet journaling they have just so many
different uses they come in different
sizes as well i have i think i have a
smaller version of this too and they
come in gridded blank and lined
and then the pens stabilo pens i've
talked about them so much still my
favorite stabilo pens are really fine
tip they come in all these different
colors and they're felt tips as well and
so it doesn't smudge or smear it's
really fun to do bullet journaling and
note taking and
journaling in general just anything
drawing as well they're all really like
nice looking as well they look really
aesthetic they look really pretty on
your desk so i have i think i got these
all together in like a pack it really
wasn't that expensive either which was
surprising given how high quality these
are i also haven't run out of ink on any
of these yet and i've had them for about
a year i don't use all of these daily i
switch out the colors and stuff but yeah
these are my favorite pens really highly
recommend these
okay the next thing that i want to
recommend that i've never talked about
on my channel before but i this is like
one of my favorite things that i own is
the rain's raincoat so yes this is a
raincoat made by a company called rains
i think they're based in copenhagen
because that's where we got ours i also
have the rain's wallet as well i love
this thing we've had ours for about two
years and we wear them on really
primarily rainy days they really are
waterproof they come in lots of
different kinds of colors scott and i
have matching navy ones and they're just
like
they're simple functional and elegant
and that's everything that you want in a
raincoat it's also actually pretty like
insulating not in like a down jacket
kind of way but it definitely like keeps
like retains heat and also doesn't let
any water in and so wearing this is
actually quite warm as a top layer on
everything else this is what it looks
like it's really cute
just like this i'll also post some
pictures from our trip where we wore
these raincoats my favorite thing about
the raincoats actually is the hat or the
hood part so let me put this hood on and
then this hood on
uh this little bill right here is what
prevents rain from getting into my face
and so genuinely better than any hood
that i've ever worn before super
protective and it's really cute it zips
all the way up
it's got two pockets on the side i got
the one with the drawstring scott has a
much more simpler straight cut one
sizing runs a little large i will say
but uh like really good investment like
raincoat jacket i'm pretty sure i will
never have to buy a raincoat again and
they really travel easy too they roll up
quite small so yeah that's it i really
hope you liked this video i hope you
learned or found out about one or two
new items that you hadn't
heard of before and that maybe you'll
buy them as gifts for yourself or for
someone you love i try to keep like a
really vast array of different things
that are really multi-functional for me
it's really important that i can use
them in lots of different scenarios and
so this is kind of like
my kit i guess i know some of these
things are kind of on the higher price
of things but also things like plants
especially if you're propagating them
are free yeah let me know what you think
if you buy any of the things below if
you gift them to anybody let me know in
the comments down below or tagging me on
social media don't forget to subscribe
to this channel if you haven't already
also if you liked my jacket you can buy
it on my merch store links down in the
description box down below i hope you'll
have a really safe and fun holiday
season and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]